hello everyone let's talk about reddit
reddit is a site where anyone can make
posts and comments relating to just
about anything let's look at one such
post ah how cute to look to the post
there are two buttons the up vote and
the down vote
according to the official retic 8 page
posts and comments are to be uploaded if
they contribute to their subreddit or
downvoted if they do not essentially
every user is a moderator of the whole
site promoting good content and weeding
out bad for the most part this works
really well at any point in time the
reddit front page will be full with
interesting and relevant posts even
though people post thousands of
uninteresting and irrelevant things
every day
so that sounds like a great system right
well sort of what we're really here to
talk about today is called the down vote
predicament which is a general problem
with reddit's voting system the
predicament is that because everyone has
a sort of moderator power on the site
people's personal beliefs biases and
agendas get in the way that is people
down vote for reasons other than what
they should be downloading for causing
lots of other issues now let's look at a
more controversial post many people will
download it because they disagree with
it and in the comments people will also
download opinions they disagree with in
the same way this is so common that many
subreddits will have a sticky post
telling users that down vote button is
not a disagree button the problem is
twofold firstly reddit places posts and
comments based on their vote score
meaning a post that was downloaded will
be lower on the page and less visible
than one that wasn't reddit even
automatically hides posts that are down
voted too much causing some users to
create many accounts to down low post
they don't like to hide them the problem
here is that minority opinions are hard
for anyone to find because people
download them for the wrong reason now
on to the second problem one of the
unintended consequences of the system is
that many ideas are sort of pre censored
let's look at an example this is Bob bob
has a great
any recipe that he wants to share with
other people on reddit he would have
posted it but after looking at his
favorite subreddit are / recipes he sees
that many dessert recipes have been
downloaded
even though Bob knows he has a great
recipe he doesn't want to risk his
reputation with a bunch of down votes so
he decides not to post it this is an
example of how a small group of people
can influence what information is shared
and seen even without downloading the
idea directly imagine that situation but
instead of a brownie recipe it's strong
opinions ideas and politics now one
counter-argument says because the
dessert recipes were downloaded people
don't want them and so this pre
censorship is good for weeding out
content people don't want why should the
brownie recipe be posted if people don't
want dessert recipes it says the problem
is that ideas are systematically
silenced in this way for everyone
despite the fact that many people like
we do want to see that content in a
place as big as the Internet also it is
hard to make this censorship argument on
reddit value page lists things like
create a safe place to encourage
participation embrace diversity of
viewpoints and allow freedom of
expression oh yeah and by the way all
these problems apply for the up vote
button as well so what can be done about
the town-ho predicament I simply hope
that because you now know why this is a
problem you'll download correctly